what don't you still not understand
because what you did what did i do you
lied to me
about what about a lot of stuff i didn't
lie to you about anything
i did not lie to you i don't know what
else to tell you
at not only this country it's unusual
for guys who have friends that are girls
and it's very unusual for girls to have
guy friends
here in america um i think if you ask
you know 100 women if they have a guy
friend it'd
probably almost be a hundred for a
hundred
i didn't do anything wrong
michael i don't get stoned at some guy's
house
and wake up half naked at his house and
call you
i never do it i wasn't naked i don't
[ __ ] i don't lie
you cheat and you lie and you get caught
this is the problem and i cannot stand
it
i don't need to explain anything else
i've explained this to you michael you
had sex with you you did right now you
just make up everything
it's it's true what i'm saying we can
connect to him
why do you continue to dig into it
because there's nothing it's over with
you're here
michael you betrayed me i didn't betray
you
i can't even go to a restaurant and
order from the waitress
michael i'm not joking you're the most
jealous person like live
you'll get all crazy and start yelling
at me as soon as we leave the restaurant
you are extremely jealous why are you
so jealous
i never was jealous to my ex-husband
because he never gave me a reason
you gave me many reasons
right natalie it's true michael it's
true and you know it
right and it's funny because i'm much
beautiful than you
your beauty is ugly really it is okay
just because you think you're the most
hottest in the world
doesn't make you a great person but i'm
okay
i don't cheat you i'm not cheating you
do no i don't
you're ignoring me instead of working on
me and you we are physically right here
you don't care about me
you